servus und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge der hacker schon heute york
heute wieder dran und wir immer gemacht
kurz die klassische ried übergabe bevor
wir anfangen noch mal die aufforderung
schickt fleißig fleißig fleißig fleißig
eine sendung ein
momentan stehen die chancen gar nicht so
schlecht dass man reinkommt in die
hacker show gibt vollgas mit euren
einsendungen dann ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit ziemlich hoch dass er
so wie die heutigen fünf leute in die
kasse kommt wir legen damit platz eins
wie heißt der beste fast björk aber auch
nicht wenn man nicht putten kann ich bin
direkt für hier du weißt schon gemerkt
aber wir sehen mal genau gleich hat er
sie auch einfach getäuscht vielleicht
was aber wirklich ein schlechter fast
besser hätte es doch wie geht das noch
junge leute aber die ganze zeit hoch und
mit straight zurück reportet richtig
lächerlich leute gerade abgebaut neues
entwickelt ab wo siehst du die und bei
dem spielmodus geht es tatsächlich darum
dass man macht sich ja anscheinend oder
one's back aktiviert steht ja an der
seite keine ahnung sagt jetzt wirklich
noch nicht aber nie von dem server
golfern behördenfunknetz aber das ist
halt nicht so erfolgen der ist einfach
kein weg
es geht hier darum wahrscheinlich dass
man first pitch und üben kann
da geht es dabei darum wirklich schnell
zu sein und dann müsst ihr wieder zurück
teilt vorstellen kannst wieder weiter
warum dann mit mehreren leuten in einer
runde sein keine ahnung ich verstehe das
nicht
auf jeden fall so oder so hätte ich bin
ich dachte es geht darum dass man als
erstes die dir blöcken wir sind ja dann
gewonnen und so mancher wird mal wieder
zurück reportieren kann anhalt weiter
öffnen machu picchu sinnvollste
spielmodus sixteen bist du musst ja weil
sie zu richten auf diesen vergleich
sowas effektiver ja stimmt genau der typ
da oben drüber fertig um drüber klopf
klopf klopf einer okay leute in dem
spielmodus wo es darum geht dass man
fest mit hecken einfach für mich
das ist echt lecker das ist das ist ein
fucking next level leider dass es fast
kann fasst mit lobby hätten konkurrieren
experten sind sie noch unsicher ob das
die ag kooperieren kann aber es ist
chaos dran
okay leute platz vier heißt bwsg
confirmed hacker aufheben und dem platz
habe ich ausgewählt nicht weil er den
aller krassesten hacker drin hat eine
kleine spezialität die jetzt gleich
sehen werden
alle hatten spaß auto okay das war wie
wir unser hacker und da müssen wir jetzt
einfach mal ein stück zurück die ihr
kind in einem it gilera der kommentar
versuchte er für ein gutes headset
allein diese vorstellungen
dann stehe die verbindung nicht wirklich
kennt kennst du das nicht
das gab irgendwo irgendwann angefangen
hast du so wenn wir irgendwie mal so
richtig krass heckt oder so was man so
sagt so direkt nicht nur gut
gefrühstückt oder die hatten kasse
gaming studie zum ersten das mit dem
headset gesehen weil wir schon mal
weiter als ein einzelner passiert ja ok
alles klar
richtig state alter
ebenso der schaut immer sofort zurück
wie bitte das geist ist die verpackung
auch immer so peinlich ne sk
durchwischen es geliebt ich bestimmt
auch per clip also okay was das fanherz
zeit hat er was meinst du auf jeden fall
1 sp konzern also dass dein gütesiegel
hat das ja aber da der locker locker in
500 euro headset liebe meine ich will
nicht übertreiben heute ich will nicht
übertreiben ich glaube dazu 100 euro
erzählt hat er 150 euro 150 euro
wer also ist es nicht das krasseste
headset aller zeiten er hat jetzt nicht
die einzigsten rom geflogen oder so aber
150 euro headset durchaus endlich sagen
so leute platz 3 heißt n joy skater in
meinem ohr machten ich lese nicht vorher
will damit bis ins feuern alles klar
ich glaube die rede noch ein bisschen
mein base ist komplett das ist ja gar
denkt der größte deutsche server ist der
letzte tipps richtig
der stirb ist das spiel vorbei immer
sagt mir dass es den gegnern nicht so
leicht machen will ist bei der bank
alter wieder auch hin und her was junge
ist ja nicht mehr scharf an
das ist ja nicht mehr feierlich freunde
die wissen den treffen man kann es ja
gar nicht treffen das heftig
ja ständig alter also sind es vier gelbe
glaube ich ging ein grünen fünf games
oder fünf gelbe alles da unter normalen
bedingungen binden wir halt locker
gewinnen
sie sind auch normale bedingungen oder
eigentlich ja als ich meine der anlage
halten ordentliches headset aber ja man
merkt an der soundqualität von denen die
aufnahmen jetzt noch fensters der hat
nicht so die besten ja klar ich meinte
deswegen können nicht fliegen wenn die
krise haben der hat er locker also
dessen locker 250 euro leute die gerade
getroffen
das ist aber deshalb locker 250 euro az
s café tontaubenschießen oder mio
das eins zu eins tontaubenschießen der
typ fliegt rum und die anderen wollen
auf ihn drauf usa möchte irgendwann
endet wo die getroffen
für die einbindung wurde im alter mann
rücken
ich habe eine idee was du machen kann
ich habe vor rückenschmerzen digger geil
als ihr wollt jetzt bestimmt zweiten
platz 10 2 heißt einfach in uk und ich
nur 25 sekunden lang leute die ich muss
schmackhaft er ist mega kurz aber ist
knackig aber wir müssen auch ganz
ehrlich sagen leute dass wir diese woche
so ein bisschen knappheit mit den
einsendungen hatten
das heißt wir hatten weniger einsatz in
den wochen davor was auch daran liegt
dass youtube meine videos einfach nicht
mehr anzeigt nicht mehr vor spielt so
wie bei den letzten tagen einfach
entschieden sorge der youtuber und den
ich über die tiger nicht mehr was sie
zum beispiel auch einfach aus dem nichts
haben sich bei dem auch er wird die user
wird genau über dieses mega komisch aber
ich will mich nicht beschweren
wir sind trotzdem noch ganz gute sachen
dabei nur falls ihr euch wundert warum
jetzt nicht so ultra finalerfolgen dabei
sind liegt daran dass wir ein bisschen
knapper 1 0 deswegen schickt ein was das
zeug hält
bis nächste woche und wie ein
regenwolken und ich kann mich über den
tresen und publikum warum jetzt auf ich
verstehe das nicht
die schüler schon ein cocktail helfrich
verstehen wollen dollar auf 1 815 chat
er fragt welcher client oben gespielt
punkt ericsson alles klar
sie ist jetzt auch schon in der hacker
szene drin acker seinem papier angeboten
hacker sind das ist eine riesen
verschwörung ist apotheker die welt
gegen uns ist es aufgefallen die welt
gegen max mich und alle hacker zuschauer
diese alle sind gegen uns verschworen
hacker senf um gespielt jetzt auch noch
nicht eingespielt hat mir vertraut alles
klar also er klebt da an der wand ja
finde ich auf jeden fall gut mit dem
ungespielt punkt sechste client ich weiß
nicht ist es ist es etwas kann auch sein
dass er einfach mit extrem guter
gaming-ausrüstung schild ja ich glaube
eher letzteres kann keiner wirklich sein
also und darf das nicht ausschließen das
kann wirklich sein dass er einfach
extrem gute gaming ausrüstung hat man
müsste an dieser stelle wirklich mal
rausfinden was für ein headset der junge
hat um besser bewerten zu können
ganz ehrlich leute wissen was ist es
mega ungerecht was bisher passiert ist
irgendwelche leute werden aufgenommen
dabei wie sie angeblich hecken weil sie
herum fliegen oder killer haben
das wird moderatorin gezeigten band
leute dann ganz ehrlich mods auf
deutschen servern
wisst ihr was für headsets die leute
haben
die leute platz eins besteht sowie der
rest episode eigentlich nur besteht die
ganze folge heute aus leuten die
entweder nicht hätten und dann leuten
die halt richtig sinnlos hätten also
wieder so ganz klassisch sinnlos und die
folge hier platz eins heißt zwei dumme
fleischacker wir sind glaube ich wieder
auf mein plex hier ja die spiels brief
glaube ich ins team und der bewegt es
wirklich nicht
der titel sagt theoretisch 2 das habe
ich halt selbst aber nie gesehen als ich
habe schon mann gesehen der enns blieb
irgendwie scheiße gemacht habe ich habe
noch nie zwei leute gesehen die in
privaten voll wie soll das gehen wenn
beide fliegen ja dann gibt's ja kein
gewinner
oh ja ok beiden mario ja ja ja ja
worüber sich gegenseitig zu erledigen
das war ein jahrzehnt ein feiner luft
alles daher mario act und piszczek da
hinten aber auch bei optimal zusammen
unter einer decke stecken
www die gegner kindesalter bitte
mitbringen
es ist total unspektakulär kugler geil
alter so muss das sein
beide schweben einfach der luft und
schießt aber die ganzen web und 321 gibt
einfach ein timeout
dass das ist einfach das ist eine perle
leute ist eine perle geschichte einfach
eine runde
tnt ist rief die einfach damit endet
dass zwei leute in der luft schweben
sinn des spiels auf jeden fall
ausgehebelt
wahrscheinlich kennen diesen so
wahrscheinlich wurden die neben einer
wahrscheinlichen nachbarn im echten
leben und die treffen sie einfach hier
und okay leute max muss jetzt zum mathe
lernen wir entlassen euch mit diesem
wunderschönen bildern vom zwei blocks
brief äckern die nebeneinander in der
luft stehen angeles rihanna jeden fall
alles leute das war's von dieser folge
der hacker schon okay macht natürlich
gefallen hat und schickt weiß ich
einfach nichts folge bis dahin und